the sexes are different for a reason
right selection made them different for
a reason it's a division of labor issue
right
and that doesn't mean it's good right
that doesn't mean it's great or
fantastic or fun or wonderful it's just
true it's just true and it means that it
is squarely within the
uh subject matter for legitimate science
right right yes we can talk about
whether it's good or bad or whether
there's something to be done to
change things that are unfair about it
because there are certainly some things
that are unfair yeah right but yeah
there's a reason for instance that
renacci sorry but like in academia
there is an active discussion about how
to deal with the fact that in general
the years during which you are most
likely to be hardest at work doing
research and building your lab are also
the most likely to be your childbearing
years if you are a woman and tenure is
on a clock and how do you stop the
10-year clock or pause it or adjust it
so as to both allow for the fact that
women also have children when they
choose to
but women also may want to be
high-powered academics and it's you you
cannot disappear the fact that there is
a trade-off there and that there's going
to be a cost but there's an active often
good faith discussion about how to do
this how to make it fair both to male
academics
who
even if they are active active daddies
don't have to go through gestation and
lactation sorry no male does
but uh
so that that's the kind of conversation
that we can have and that we should be
having and hey we were having
in the 80s and 90s and otts about what
the differences between the sexes
and moving beyond regressive old
expectations of gender roles means as we
move forward into a world in which
everyone has the ability to choose
freely from among their options about
what it is that they want to do with
their lives right and i mean in fact
we've
this is a demonstration that our ability
to talk openly about this issue actually
leads to solutions right because the
fact is academia has been democratized
between the sexes it didn't start out
that way but if you look at the number
of uh female phds graduating it exceeds
males in the sciences at least um
uh in biology i'm not i don't think in
the sciences across the board
uh
certainly not in engineering and
engineering it's it's it's highly skewed
as we would expect it to remain we want
to see a
composite analysis mds are are biased uh
towards towards women at this point uh
and i think a bit you know again this
you know this this old saw which is
based on research and which is true is
that on average women are more
interested in people and also organisms
and on average men are more interested
in things means that men are more likely
given freedom of choice to go into
things like engineering and math and
physics and chemistry and women are more
likely to go into medicine and
biology of whole organisms yep all right
but suffice it to say we have addressed
this problem and we did so not by
pretending that sex differences didn't
exist but by recognizing that they had
implications for career tracks and by
making reasonable changes to the way
power was distributed in these
departments
[Music]
you